Here are two methods for decreasing
when knitting one by one ribbing.
The simplest method is to just transfer the edge Stitch
to the opposite needle bed use your double eye
needle tool and remove the knit stitch from the
needle push the empty needle into out of work.
Transfer that Stitch from the tool to the ribber needle
doubling up the stitches and knit two rows.
Your next step is to slip the ribber Stitch to the double-wide
needle and transfer up to the main bed
and double up the knit stitch knit two rows work
the decreases as instructed in your pattern.
As many times as you need
the resulting Edge is smooth and clean
if you're going to seem to ribbed edges
you may want to use this method.
There's more transferring of stitches, but you're
left with a seeming Stitch along the edge.
Transfer the ribber Stitch to the main bed doubling
up the second Stitch from The Edge then transfer
the edge knit stitch down to the ribber
this decreases one stitch.
Again, transfer the main bed Stitch down to the second
ribber Stitch and move the edge ribber Stitch
to the main bed decreasing
another Stitch.
Now keep in mind with this method The Edge Stitch will
always be a single stitch all the decreases.
The doubled-up stitches are worked
on the Stitch next to the edge.
As you can see the edge initially doesn't appear to be
as neat as the simple method but there's a stitch
along the edge to make seeming easier the Knit It
Now learning library has many shaping technique
tutorials for other needle Arrangements plus
tips and tricks for mastering your ribber.
Thanks for watching and happy knitting.